So I mimics estrogen. So if I don't have cancer
Would eating organic fermented so I help increase my estrogen levels
I postman a puzzle and my Dutch test
Confirmed that estrogen is very low. Thank you
Okay, so so if you if your estrogen levels are really low
Could you eat so I to bring your estrogen levels up a little bit?
Well, I would eat soy iso flavonoids
It's a it's a constituent of so I but it's not just eating like tofu or so a product
So it's it's gonna have the benefits of helping balance your estrogens
But it's not going to like spike your estrogens. It's not gonna give you the negative zero estrogens that could cause issues in your body
fermented soy is the chimino fermented soy works differently in your body than the soy
Oddly, there are some studies that fermented soy actually can decrease your estrogen load
so
If you're trying to increase your estrogens, I guess fermented soy wouldn't be the choice
Now understand the benefit of fermented soy really lies with people that have
Cancer especially estrogen receptor positive cancer
Because fermented soy has been shown to dislodge
Those bad estrogens from the receptor sites from the beta estrogen receptor sites on the cancer cells
which
When bad estrogens attach to that beta estrogen site it actually blocks extrinsic apoptosis
And fermented soy has been shown to dislodge that now
Regular soy increases your estrogen load which can then degrade into the four hydroxy esterone
Which can be that bad estrogens that attaches to that
Estrogen beta receptor so
There's a very difference if a person has cancer
They and especially if they have estrogen or progesterone or hurt too positive cancer
They don't want to be eating soy
But fermented soy they do want to eat because it can actually work the opposite of soy
It dislodges that bad estrogen from that receptor site
Allowing a greater degree of acoptosis to take place
so
It stands to reason at least I believe that fermented soy is not going to increase your estrogen levels
So I don't think to answer that question I don't think fermented soy would be the choice
I would use soy, I self-lay but obviously you have to get that supplement form